I was I was like kind of playing the
music for it she was up here we've got a
short a bottle of champagne she went on
the balcony and she just said thanks for
everything that you've done give us a
cuddle and everything and then she got
on the bed the intravenous trip was put
in and she was fine we was nuttering
away about the things we'd been doing
and then you have to go through the
questions again so you know like what's
your name what's your date of birth
where are you I think I said I'm in
Switzerland why have you come to
Switzerland I've come to die Don said I
just I don't want to die alone
and it was said don't worry we're going
to hold you around right till the end
you won't die alone
um tell my son that I love him and that
was it she just like
well a jaw dropped straight away so it
must have been fairly fairly quickly
what would you hope that your last week
day looked like what would that be for
you music drink
and whether you can broadcast so this or
not weed lots and lots of weed
I chose the habit of a life sorry